thank you oh
thank you please thank you you're a
fantastic audience
thank you i know what i know why i'm
happy today because this is our last
show
here from my man cave going back to the
studio
next week and not a moment too soon
because you know it was hot boy we got a
heat wave here in california
we got in l.a we got these rolling
blackouts that's a little different
rolling blackout in l.a that's when you
lose your electricity while you're high
on molly
yeah oh it's hot here uh local officials
are urging looters to stay hydrated
um and we gotta we got a new thing i'm
not making this up
fire tornadoes how do you do you love
california always ahead of the curve
on new trends and a fire tornadoes boy
now look i know this sounds like
something you don't want but remember
you said that about podcasts and anal
sex
oh and speaking of on fire
did you see the democratic convention
hashtag sarcasm
oh man that thing how do you describe it
it's like you ever tune into the jerry
lewis telethon at like two in the
morning
it was a lot like that um but it
accomplished what it had to accomplish
joe biden
accepted the nomination this week in a
uh uh high school
library uh oh it gets worse and an old
lady came out and shushed him
uh wednesday night obama spoke he killed
it took the gloves off against trump he
said trump has
no interest in doing the work
and trump was so pissed about that that
he missed a two-foot putt
[Applause]
also joe you know he's going after the
youth vote so he was interviewed by
cardi b and uh yeah she interviewed and
uh
biden said that his daughter gave him a
nickname joey b
and he also has a a rap name you know
that joe biden yes it's a the fresh
fresh prince of smell hair
yeah joe asked cardi you know as as
politicians do
uh you know what are the issues that are
of interest to you that
matter to you and she cardi said she
wants free health care
she wants free college and she wants
racial justice and joe said hey whatever
gets your [ __ ] wet
but no it was it was a very very nice
interview and it ended well
at the end cardi said this is why i will
vote for you
and joe said and this is why i picked
you as my running mate
joe is that i get you
but hey big news out of the senate the
senate intelligence committee this week
released their report
on trump and russia and big surprise yes
there was quite a bit of collusion
uh trump's campaign manager paul
manafort get this was using
ten different encrypted messaging apps
like wicker signal 3m fiber
voxer hush mail sounds a little fishy
thank god he wasn't using a private
email server
but let me just reiterate finally next
week we are
back in the studio now there are some
trade-offs there yes there's a slightly
greater risk of infection but
a much lower risk of stepping in dog
[ __ ] after
new rules